talk of the day he'll be telling you
spent the whole mental privacy and
winning afterwards there's a reception
right outside you won't miss it plans to
stick around a little bit all right yeah
so compared to the wonderful talks by
Cohen Allen in the car beer there's
going to be like all right compared to
canal stock there's going to be pure
proofs so I want you to kind of lower or
raise your expectations depending on how
you feel we can do it's like reset your
expectations so what is so when we talk
about local so so far we've been talking
about the just plain differential
privacy as I will be speaking about
local differential privacy I want to
define it relative to what's not local
which is central and the central
differential privacy for the purpose of
this talk is going to be your standard
definition of privacy and when we have a
single traitor that interacts with the
database or a single analyst who issues
queries a to a database and we care
about differential privacy of the entire
transcript of its Entropia interaction
and by the way look the colors are very
washed out so kind of you're supposed to
be seeing some light salad green you
don't
so like trust me so each of these
interactions is locally differentially
private and that what that means is that
data is held by its original owner
instead of pooling their data into a
single data set there are holding on to
their own individual records they're
minding their own data and whenever they
interact with the creator or anyone else
in the world there are like they're
wearing this like tinfoil hats like
they're worrying about the world being
against themselves like being the entire
world being in step
so they're they're taking account each
participant of the data set considers
its entire interaction interaction with
the world as a transcript of that
reflects its sensitive content so this
is the standard definition of a
differential privacy and you've seen it
a hundred times the food before you have
seen that a bunch of time today by
sometimes today right and the treats the
distribution of the output on database D
is nearly the same as the output on and
on G prime for all adjacent databases GM
G prime and this root adjacent or a
neighboring databases it's it's very
application dependent like sometimes we
talk about the the entry like level
privacy will be a talk encouraging
privacy to a single action that the
person takes we like to talk about two
database being adjacent or a neighboring
when the different revisions of a single
individual but like we can consider
different units of green relation and
local differential privacy takes it to
the eleventh so we want the distribution
of the are all of the transcripts be
closed for all possible inputs
the of course like under this definition
we wouldn't be able to do much but kind
of you have to realize that as the
definition applies to each individual
record altogether like across all the
records we are able to learn something
on trill about about about the world and
this is what this part of our tutor was
going to be about how to protect to
offer this relatively extreme level of
privacy while doing something useful and
we call it local differential privacy
and I'll say in a few slides
we're kind of where were they straight a
phrase appeared it's interesting to note
that what we would now call local
different different a private mechanisms
actually precedes the notion of
differential privacy so the well
extremely well studied and like a
storage method from statistics called
randomize response and like I put
together the original reference going
back to 1965 by Stanley Werner I put
here just like basically with a random
monograph
the just about the randomize response
and it's multiple variants and this
method what we now recognize is a
prototypical locally different reprise
mechanism was proposed to elicit answers
to sensitive questions and to give an
example not completely random I take
this question are you a citizen of the
United States where are you illegal
residents of the United States and to
apply this method we consider this
question and it's complement which is
our you're not as it is not of the
United States and according to the
original workers methods
a person chooses privately without
revealing its its its random coins or
chooses privately and randomly without
worrying in certain coins which of the
two questions the person is going to
answer and then it becomes a truly like
elementary statistical just now exercise
to back out of the so if II each each
person follows this procedure and theta
is the true fraction of people who are
citizens in the sample like by the way
do you know what is the approximate
number of citizens in this country the
percentage-wise
make it yes HSN percent so if it is the
actual fraction of citizens then and if
each person forces this procedure that
the number of yes the fraction of the
yeses will be given by this formula and
for from this you can back out a
unbiased estimator for for this fraction
and you can compute to all kinds of the
concentration bounce the variances etc
what about privacy it's again just
consider this but this one interaction
with the world with probability P a
person answers question one with
probability 1 is P it answers the
question with the opposite answer and
it's very it's trivial to see that the
this interaction satisfies this level of
differential privacy and here I'm
assuming that P is larger than 1/2 yes
like less No
so here kind of I'm showing my favorite
pictures that we put together to explain
local differential pressure financial
privacy we randomized response to people
who kind of would have problem
interpreting this light and I kind of
I'm sure that every one of you could
kind of follow every last line of this
light so this pictures are that you can
use to show kind of the wire randomized
responses if an effective technique to
people without mathematical background
so imagine that like we have this like
this population and people look in
arranging themselves in the like or in
this image of Mona Lisa and each person
holds onto their own private value will
will flip with probability twenty five
percent each of this each of these bits
and locally we can see that like we
offer a non-trivial level of privacy to
each other to each of the individuals
and non trivial and quantifiable level
of privacy but if you zoom out then we
can still very much ruggedized Mona Lisa
yeah so if our purpose in conducting
this experiment was to kind of know on
how like Renaissance women look like but
we succeeded
so the even like this Rose the thrill of
trivial formulation of randomized
response that I offered and also some
for some interesting creative and highly
original work for example the one which
I liked a lot was a protocol up by Tom
Warren at one in our who described how
to enforce the correct probability of
kind of lying or like flipping your bit
using scratch cards so if you follow the
protocol then you'll end up and like I
want I'm not going to describe the
protocol sounds just kind of there's a
reference and there's like the protocol
is really simple is like fits on a
single single slide if you follow the
product the protocol then you'll either
end up sampling your bid from a card
distribution where you kind of end up
with an invalid scratch card obviously
you can lie about your input like to
yourself like you can be delusional like
the scratch card protocol is not going
to help you but if you're kind of sort
of not kind of are going to participate
in the protocol then the there's no it
almost the requirement of like slipping
a bit in like behind the scenes and not
telling everyone about it ok so now on
to the a bit more like coming coming in
looking for recent history so local
differential privacy appeared like worse
described and several separate
communities under different names and
like put I put down a few references
that are like appear often in papers
that talk about the local different
private model but this is the paper that
that introduced the coins the term local
different her private model right was it
and so it introduces the model it proved
a very significant result stating that
classes learn about that model are
exactly the same classes of of concept
classes that are allowable in the
statistical query model it demonstrated
an efficient differential private local
epidural for the provision function
which separates it from certain order so
it demonstrated an effusion differential
private learner known in the loan local
model for the pricing function that
separated the central differential
privacy from the local differential
private models
I yep and so it did demonstrate that
this models are meaningfully different
and in kind of in this in the middle
part of the talk I'll go through several
canonical problems in local differential
provision and before I do that I want to
give you some opportunity to ask
questions about the model itself
so I'll say a few words so it's
important to differentiate between the
definition and an architecture so the
definition of local differential privacy
doesn't tell you who's doing what in
what sequence in particular when we talk
about local general privacy
it's convenient to think of people hold
on to their own data oftentimes it's
it's more efficient to implement the LDP
model by putting data together by by
pulling data in the central repository
randomizing in the repository and and
only storing this randomized data right
so I want you to kind of keep it and
I'll make even a stronger statement that
a particular protocol any particular
architecture can simultaneously
simultaneously satisfy multiple
definitions of privacy so for example
and some of our recent work does fall
into this category we can orchestrate a
competition between multiple parties
such that each of them enjoys some level
of local differential privacy but what
the central server sees satisfies
central differential provision so the
protocol is the same
it's the bits Malaysia satisfies a list
of different privacy privacy definitions
so and
I think kind of there's an ongoing
argument whether look different her
privacy somehow like it's like if you'd
leave or look at kind of white washes go
ahead
I've been baking UI is it a tick if
they're a technical reason to do the one
or the other or is it rather a question
where the company says you know the
users don't trust me because if the
users trust at me they would just give
the data and then I will do
maybe is that the optimal thing or are
they technical reasons for preferring
the local differential privacy not just
a trust so
technically look mathematically the
central model is offers better accuracy
and much high efficiency computational
cost are much lower compared to the
local different differential private
model so if you don't care about privacy
then left to their own devices it's in
virtual majority of cases it's cheaper
to pull data look into a singular
project area and keep it there
I can come up with like some examples
where it might not be the case for
example if the competition especially
look if the uploads are particularly
expensive you want to minimize what
travels from user devices to to the to
the center layer and there's an
asymmetry like for your cell phone to
send it out cause much more than to
receive data from it so there are some
kind of news cases where you can make a
technical argument for local
differential privacy but realistically
it all comes down to the question of
trust and what companies can which one
want to collect oftentimes the
understand the risks and they would much
rather not touch the data or touch it
but like at a very using this very kind
of narrow interface
certainement maybe you could speak a
little more about this issue of trust
like from your experience whether this
is something that the company can
measure or like how about this decisions
are made and the related question is
what are these decisions what are the
decisions are also related to you know
fear more about subpoena or something
like that it is a real thing
okay so like well we speak about
companies you have to understand that
like the companies are not monolith and
this like a local differential privacy
and like this with the particles are run
inside companies too so whatever like my
view of the world is it can be very
different from view of the same problem
from like the C office or from like the
legal office so I don't think that kind
of I can in all fairness
answer this question like based on my
experience but so in what I've seen the
kind of the with large sophisticated
companies like Google Microsoft the
understand that some data is better not
or is better left not collected so it's
not it's like the question of trust and
reliability I would say that like its
liability not in a legal sense but in
the sense that like oh my god like if we
bring this data in it increases it
incurs all kinds of costs and but it's a
constant dialogue within the company
like between various offices and it's it
gets remarkably it's also history
dependent but it's also kind of
companies are watching what kind of the
press is saying what the process saying
about other companies so we are all part
of
like very many voiced conversation are
you aware of any measurement taken to
sort of so there is there are constant
measurements taken to to evaluate
whether customers understand privacy
policies and how the respond to them I'm
but I'm not conducting the study seems
like I haven't like I haven't seen the
decision being made on the basis of the
study alone it like feeds into this
narrow look into this understanding what
would what is currently acceptable and
like how the privacy policy gets
crackers I'm sorry for like not giving
you camp a crisp as a satisfying answer
but it's also reality of working in a
corporation with like two hundred
thousand employers that like there are
like multiples trees shaking at the same
time by multiple individuals and yep
okay so now back to the math so let's so
oh let me introduce a few canonical
problems that are interesting and like
allow me Chia and non-trivial solutions
in the local differential privacy model
so one problem that was I think it was
in the it's in the original formulation
goes back to Warner like to the
randomizer run Bart's response but it's
it's Lobo incentive completely its
treatment was was initiated by a female
and copyin hombre and it's about joining
the population mean so each person holds
on to their binary so they're a bit and
we want to come compute the sum of these
bits so without the local interpret
differential privacy constraint if we
could aggregate this bits together we
could compute their sound with epsilon
differential privacy with an error would
be inversely proportional to 2f
so Epsilon so the kind of we'd like to
see how low the error for in the local
defer her private model model can go so
any error that is much larger than one
over epsilon will separate the models
will tell us that we can do more in the
central Keys than we can do in the local
keys oops
my my animations off but so consider the
following experiment each person
randomly selects one of their bits so
initially all their bits are truly
random the engage in the protocol in the
way I drew it it's a central parts a
communicating which each of these
individuals it doesn't have to be this
way the communication car drive can be
arbitrary and one basic fact in in
communication theory is that conditioned
on the transcript the bits that will
independent one another will stay
independent
and look the first time I saw it I kind
of didn't believe it the second time I
didn't believe it either but like it
takes kind of it is exercise to to
verify that exchanging messages of
course condition conditions the bit of
the party that sent a message but
doesn't introduce any dependencies yeah
so the bits are still independent and
because of the local high pressure
privacy constraint conditioned on the
transcript each of the bit will retain
some non-trivial entropy and then here I
can apply a site Berry is a Essen
theorem which is like a heavy hammer
there like because we are talk about
like binary values that like are
separated from from either zero one you
can actually prove a very simple anti
concentration equality and the reason is
it basically a what you find quantified
version of the central limit theorem
what that says is that like it's just
the constants are explicit so
conditioned on the transcript the sum of
the of the bits will be spread over an
interval of the size of roughly square
to pan around an oval to so any
estimator that is trying to to compute
to approximate the sum of the bits will
make a error of the order of square
defects with like some exclusive
definition epsilon
and so just think about it as in the
central differential private keys the
error of the of the sum is independent
it only depends on the privacy parameter
epsilon is local different her private
key privacy keys
it increases with M okay so it tells us
that the local different her private
model is fundamentally more challenging
to Britain than the central model the
next canonical problem in l GP is
learning what's called heavy hitters so
let me describe look introduced the
problem and so the papers that kind of
made it significant progress on this
problem we first just by came out of
google by over Alexandria and Priscilla
whistle before then Ralph and Adam and
then like the Europe's paper from 2017
is the one on which I'm kind of mostly
follow my presentation so the heavy
hitters I changed the name reflectively
so the heavy cleaners problem is the
following we have a distribution over
some some universe and the server size
of this universe is going to be some of
her our constructs and we want to output
the items the top key items out of this
universe the items with the heavy
support and together with there are
frequencies and we'll be trying to
minimize the L infinity distance like
the lowest error over this K items the
items which are kind of didn't make the
cut we'll say that there are kind of
computers frequency is less is like it
zero so we kind of explicitly we should
compute frequencies for K items and
implicitly for everyone else we set it
to zero so as I just cut like just
designing this solving the heavy-hitters
problem is the local different tribe and
and how is it related to the LDP model
each person holds a an element of the
universe and the histogram for which we
are trying to compute heavy heavy
hitters is the distribution over these
people so we interact with a single
person holding on to their element of
the universe at a time
so let's forget about privacy for a
moment let's just talk about
communication complexity and and in the
no private keys will be using what's
called the what was introduced as the
count sketch in 2002 by Tara Carter and
others I think now this nickname is the
count means sketch and it's it has it
takes the following form
each client it has its own element of
the yours say string only it has two
hash functions one hash function or like
it has two x key functions it has for
each K for each line of this matrix it
has exactly two functions one function
is an index in the column of the matrix
and the second function is just a it's a
it's a sine plus or minus one the
definition of the sketch is the
following we take the string for each of
the key lights of the metrics we apply
the toss function it's like a column and
we'll put in this column the plus or
minus one where the sign is given by the
second hash function
and we'll send these mattresses to the
server and of course like in reality
like you don't have to sell you don't
have to send the zeroes look you just
sent the index and the the sign in this
index the server on its end will compute
the sum of this little matrices and it
will use the sum to construct a
frequency Oracle what is the frequency
Oracle
given an arbitrary string good arbitrary
element of the universe it will go
through each of the lines of this metric
all these metrics that have computed and
for it makes this metal competition Oh
what what column would the eyes hash
function select for the string and it
will take the element of this matrix
with the sign that each of the clients
would pick for this for the string and
it's it's real easy to see that what we
end up with and so it gets this estimate
for a number for the support of a string
for each of the of the rows of this
matrix and that will compute the median
among this estimates so conditioned over
the choice of the hash functions this is
an unbiased estimator for the support of
a string well we take the median we get
very nice concentration bounds and there
is erosion come in sketch as we proof
again I won't do it here they'll prove
some strong l2 error bound on the alto
bound on the on the total error we are
interested in the Alan Finney bounds so
kind of there's like it's not it kind of
we have to use something like there's
some block required to adapt the result
but like basically it's if you it's one
has to follow the original paper
so that was the just by-the-book
application of the count min sketch how
to add privacy to it so just instead of
the each client sending K rows will make
each client pick one row at random why
is that because if you drool do this
like privacy calculus and it ends up
more efficient like you boost the signal
to noise ratio so to speak by putting
all your eggs in one basket and sends in
this basket rather than spreading them
around this matter what does making a
sense actually kind of the right
metaphor that that abra jeep likes to
use is the following so if you have a
toast and there is a a jam on this toast
enter like asked to say whether it's a
strawberry jam where were orange jam and
you can have like two strategies one is
to kind of take a bite out of this toast
but chances are you'll miss this like
one drop of jam where you can spread the
jam around take your bite and this way
you kind of you'll have a much better
chance of of of producing the right
answer
okay so here like we sample a role in
this in this from this little metrics
this server really have to kind of scale
this this sum up summation up yes each
person contributing to all the rows each
person just picks one Road in tributes
just for you yeah yes correct
yeah yep and so the server yep so the
client picks one of the roles of the
matrix and then applies a three-way
right now mice responds like it's active
randomizing between two options a tram
randomizing between three options but
it's kind of Damascus Israel is simple
and the server can recover the estimate
for the counts of this of this metrics
and implement the same frequency Oracle
as I did before without privacy so
privacy happens here or the server side
it has to compensate for the noise that
was introduced by the search by the
clients but it's a relatively simple
operations so now like the algorithm the
basic algorithm is very simple you you
kind of have ability to to compute this
to approximate frequencies now you go
through the entire universe pick the key
heavy hitters and declare victory right
to things that kind of one has to be
aware of to do full discovery rate
because this estimates that are going to
be noisy and you don't want to output
heavy hitters that are just gathering
because of noise so this is just kind of
right look you want to do correct
statistics here but second the universe
can be a can be excessively large it can
be like all wars in the dictionary or
all words that you don't you do know
existed and in the example that average
applies to likes to offer you know it's
learning the keyboard in Mandarin where
it's common to kind of invent new
combination of characters that are just
not part of any dictionary look because
like people that want to be playful when
they avoid some kind of way some kind of
censorship
for whatever reasons or elec there's
like some recent memes
so you just this universe it exists it's
it's reasonable to limit the universe to
like six like a sequence of six
meandering characters but it's still
humongous so how do you solve this
problem so there's a you do it by asking
clients to take your that we have sent
and chopping it at on a point like just
choosing random practice of this boot
and now on the server side it starts so
I kind of don't do not list rendering
characters like I would be sticking with
the like an alphabet so the server
starts with the prefixes of one letter
each it does it selects the heavy
hitters from this prefixes the prefixes
that do have some non-trivial support
the progressed to the second rounds did
they get expanded etc and why don't we
get commentar literal explosion by only
this practical because in each level
we'll be looking at the key heavy
hitters and it's obvious that the the
true heavy hitters they'll have all the
prefixes will be heavy hitters too
you have to kind of not going to be
exactly key but you have to kind of set
up your parameters correctly okay so so
I covered two problems that had to do
with heavy hitters now like let's you're
closer to the stated topic of this
tutorial which is machine learning and
let's talk about convex optimization
that some people still care about that
hurt so in a Fox paper from 2013 dajatol
the demonstrated that a basically hdg
algorithm achieves a this guarantee with
the for when it's applied to a convex
loss function which is one Lipschitz for
all data sets in in support and let's
ponder this this formula like this
guarantee for a bit so 1 over absolute
something that were well familiar with
and like it be said it's kind of
perennial to find it here but this
multiplicative multiplicative term a
kind of sucks so it's it has both
dependence here on on the dimensionality
it gets yours as dimension gets higher
and it has this kind of no I think this
is good chip dependence here once 1 over
square root of n but that's as good as
good
the number of participants of the
protocol yeah so this is a Buddha pencil
one over epsilon square the pen is good
it's the tension on the dimensionality
wishes
so let's pause this problem of convexity
position let's put in the hole for a
second and consider the problem of
learning in the median and this problem
was was addressed in this beautiful
paper by adamant others so we are very
much used to this privacy accuracy
trade-offs but kind of what this paper
was the the insight of that paper was
that for in the local different her
private model interactivity is a huge
cost and in reality can be the main
obstruction like my main impediment to
implementation because sort of like in
the central model when you're doing
computation that's annoying but like
kind of you have to do computation in
the local differential pair boodle each
rod of communication is hugely expensive
and it makes a difference and like
running an service that collects data
from from clients is very different from
a service that wants to talk to clients
and in the local different her private
model the this dimensionality the number
of rounds of interaction is a very
significant is a very significant
characteristic of your protocol and if
we go back to to the previous slide to
do Kjetil there HDD based product
algorithm takes the number of
interactions which is proportional to
the number of participants like it's as
interactive as it gets it kind of for
each new step of the of the algorithm it
has to talk to it has to update an
internal state and talk to a different
person and in in in practice like these
round trips becomes the major cost like
the major drag on your implementation so
let's consider like a the very really
the I would say a canonical example of a
one dimensional convex problem which is
completing the median in the median is
the the minimizer of the kind of the
some of the other one distances from
from points on a single owner
one-dimensional line so without thinking
too much how would we solve the finding
the median using the binary search we
have some bounds on where the medium
might live and we'll ask people using
our favorite randomize response protocol
whether what is the fraction of people
who have data to the right of the median
which will be
and then kind of will be updating like
we'll be doing this binary search here
like if more people end up on the left a
little bit like drilling down to the
left so it's nice and good but it
requires multiple interactions to get
close to the median
so wait when you say interaction do you
mean I'm updating the question for a new
distractible yep so you can any one
person only speaks once but you have to
update your internal state in between
questions
so and this is like a super nice problem
to think about and I'm so glad that
animate others like folded for us and my
animation is wrong here is like off too
but here's the project of how the
program would look like so we'll divide
so this is the range where the media
might live well divide it into halves
and for people who are reassigned to the
first cohort will ask kind of your value
doesn't leave in the left half or the
right half it's like a binary answer
left or right it will make them send us
some as their input using randomized
response for people in the second cohort
will ask two questions
so suppose like my median my value lives
here then here for this pair er I'll I'm
asked to submit my true answer is going
to be R we shall send with well personal
privacy just using random response for
this pair I'll send random answer so for
people for people in the in the second
cohort
they'll send two answers one of them is
going to be correlated with where their
median lives and the other is going to
be totally off the wall for people in
the cohort we'll be answering how many
for questions
one question is going to be correlated
with
the half where there are true median
lips and the other three questions are
going to be really random
and it's once kind of I think once the
protocol is out there like it's the
analysis kind of sort of like writes
itself and the number of samples which
is the true complexity cost for in which
we like to measure local different
locally different rubber different
private protocols if has like this very
nice dependencies on absolutes and the
the the target error the remarkable fact
about this protocol is that it's
completely non interactive you'll assign
people like where people will kind of
draw the to choose their assignments
randomly the all execute their protocols
locally we pull their answers together
and out comes the very good
approximation to the medium so what
about so I asked you earlier to suspend
the question about optimization of
convex functions or convex with musician
for the one commercial case were for
small dimensional keys it reduces to the
median again thanks to look that the
reduction is non-standard it was
demonstrated in the paper but kind of
the the the bummer is that the sample
complexity is going to be exponential in
the number of dimensions and the paper
sort of makes a fairly positive argument
that it's may not be avoidable or at
least it rules out a class of non
adaptive protocols that are based on
stochastic gradient descent methods
where you include methods which are
based in the case of gradient descent
for some artificially constructed
function
so now like I only have a few minutes
left but I covered the Syria of local
give her her privacy now let me say a
few words about its application practice
and kind of as it often happens
applications came before Syria but now I
think kind of it's down kind of the
illnesses on the applications to catch
up to exist in Syria so can the theory
and leapfrogged applications as we know
it so in about 20 2014 there was an
epidemic of what's called in Google and
wanted software which reads news so
there was an epidemic of software that
was taking over a chrome installations
and you may have seen it work you may
have seen it on your parents computers
the some kind of like ad networks taken
over the search engine were just like
completely like spamming your screen
with the with ads and it in Google
Google is a very data-driven data driven
company if you can if you cannot measure
it you cannot manage it and the first
reflex was to understand the extent of
the problem but what kind of got into
the way of collections this very
important firm ation of what search
engines
people's browsers are set to and someone
terrible power non-trivial number of the
search engines were malicious like we
were kind of actually making their
experience much worse so what prevented
Google Chrome from learning of this
information was very enlightened very
kind of strongly worded very readable
privacy policy
that fxb said that in the time that only
information that could be collected by
Chrome
from the browser was something that
could help the user in the moment one
was collected so when you were about to
go to a malware website and it wasn't a
black on a black list then the browser
legitimately akinator the policy could
go to the backend and check whether it's
still on the black list whether it's
like a false positive or not if it was
it would like flash like red and saying
don't go there that was like about the
level of like a immediate threat that
justified communication information that
happens in the browser to the back end
but it was obvious to people in the room
and like you can ask Alexandre who was
there
how kind of what went into making this
decision that the permission about that
would protect users from us was worth
collecting with appropriate privacy
constraints and this is work of rapport
which was based on Ron raddimus response
and like had several levels of the power
differential privacy which I am NOT
going to go into well it was deployed
and it's been operated by Google of
floor if yours now it's kind of it's
it's being ramped down it's still like I
think it's part of current look most
recent versions of Chrome but I don't
think there's a it will be there for
much longer we hope to replace it with
better better mechanisms for protecting
privacy but
for now so I'll skip description of
reporter and
I'll say that kind of it was a because
it was the first deployment of local
different privacy by the industry there
was a very concerted effort on getting
the message out of a channel to the
privacy advocates to journalists telling
our story a technical paper appeared at
yes I think it was very available that
liked it
it found the toy D it found its audience
and it was peer reviewed and like it put
the stamp of approval on this entire
project
the white paper got updated and contains
reference to the to the cheesiest paper
I think it was kind of a typical for
privacy policies have references to
actually research research papers it had
like a giant success within the chrome
developers who just like loved it and
use it to collect many signals beyond
what our kind of what we initially
anticipated and you may have seen like
this screenshot taken from a apples that
the bloody C Developers Conference were
Apple announced that there would be
using the parameter privacy for similar
application and in a somewhat similar
model but local differentiate private
model and then more recently Microsoft
announced that they would be using local
differential privacy for a telemetry in
Windows 10 and like there are full many
details on there a blog post and I kind
of I think there are going to measure
usage of apps the frequency at the time
of engagement with apps in Windows 10
but like I think you should better start
reading their blog and with this I
conclude
[Applause]
questions
I'm so curious about this